please welcome hayley bennett
it's so wonderful to see you this is for
you
oh my god i am so happy to see you i'm
so happy to see you i promised myself i
wouldn't cry
and here i am i opened it now we're
waiting open it now okay
oh haley i'm so happy for your life
thank you
we weren't moms when we did music and
lyrics a billion years ago we were just
kids yes it was my first time in new
york when we made the film
and
i was just so in awe i was so i'm from
ohio i was just so in awe of being in
the big city doing a film with you
with hugh
um drew and hugh um and i remember the
casting director lovely eileen
she said can you learn a dance
can i learn a dance i'm not a dancer so
i went to like one of britney spears's
um former dancers to teach me a dance in
the valley
and the next day i was meant to fly for
this um screen test and i remember like
being down on all fours and just
stopping
and being like i'm so sorry i can't do
this
i'm
so embarrassed there was and they were
so wonderful and gracious i'm like i'm
so sorry i should i think i'm gonna go
back to ohio now
like get the first plane back to ohio
and yet and yet that was the beginning
of a long and illustrious career i mean
you have not stopped working since then
ever
oh my gosh you're not going to believe
this all i've wanted is fingerless
gloves thank you for your answering my
prayers
[Applause]
oh they're so beautiful
with love and this is such an intimate
gift like i'll be thinking of you and
holding your heart and my heart and your
hand knit gloves thank you so much
fingerless thank you
okay so you did get the part
and then holy cow i'm sorry your shoes
are so incredible
in fact
might they not be a beautiful dovetail
and parlay into how did you celebrate
that win of winning the park uh well so
i was living very close to fifth avenue
and i
marched my way over to fifth avenue and
bought shoes and ever since then i've
had a great love affair with shoes but
they were the most amazing green marc
jacobs shoes and they were
so expensive yeah and
now i have a whole closet full of overly
expensive shoes carrie bradshaw like
like major carrie bradshaw uh maybe
worse but also the other thing that i
bought was a bottle of perfume which
there's a little bit left and i'm saving
it for my wedding
and you're engaged yes and
your fiance joe wright is one of the
most
renowned important filmmakers in our
industry if you love pride and prejudice
atonement hannah you name it it is all
anna karenina all from the mind of your
extraordinary fiancee
and
now
you're doing sereno with him what was
what is it like to be in love with the
man who is directing you what is that
like a lot of pressure
um although
um
yeah it works for some people it doesn't
work for other people it really works
for us we're looking forward to making
more films together
um
and
it's great yeah and he's the most
incredible like humble loving kind
you know
the heart that goes into his films it's
just
can you unlike anyone i've ever worked
with like because yeah if a really
renowned director is telling me what to
do i'm like great i want to know what
you think i have my own arsenal to work
with i want yours absolutely there is so
much trust involved between actor and
director so to already show up with that
established
was yeah was was really was really
useful
[Music]
you